YOURS.
TO THE ECONOMY FOR WHICH IT
STANDS, ONE ECONOMY WITH OPEN
BORDERS AND LOW WAGES FOR ALL.
HENRIQUE ESTEVAN AUTO IS AN
ANCHOR FOR UNIVISION, AND HE
JOINS US NOW.
YOU SEEM LIKE A REASONABLE
PERSON, HOW DID YOU END UP IN
THE GROUP DEFENDING MS-13?
>> I DON'T THINK ANY HUMAN BEING
AS AN ANIMAL, TUCKER.
BUT I'M NOT HERE TO DEFEND
CRIMINALS OR ANYONE ELSE.
IF YOU ARE FOR A LAW AND ORDER,
I DON'T THINK DEGRADING ANYONE
TO A HUMAN SERVES THAT PURPOSE.
YOU WOULD EXPECT THE
TO SPEAK TO NOT JUST THE WORST
IDEALS.
>> Tucker: SO MS-13 GANGS
STABBED A MAN 100 TIMES,
DECAPITATED HIM AND RIPPED OUT
HIS HEART.
THEY BEAT A TRAFFIC GIRL WITH A
ABOUT 13 TIMES.
A NATION SATANIC SHRINE, THEY
KIDNAPPED AND A 13-YEAR-OLD GIRL
KIDNAPPED AND A 13-YEAR-OLD GIR
GIRL.
YOU GET OFFENDED, WHY?
WHY WOULD PEOPLE WHO DO THAT
NEED TO BE DEFENDED BY YOU?
WHAT ABOUT WHAT TRUMP SAID GOT
YOU GOING?
>> I THINK WE CANNOT PRETEND TO
LOOK AT THIS IN A LARGER
CONTEXT.
WE CANNOT PRETEND THAT THIS IS
STARTED WAY BEFORE DONALD TRUMP
BECAME PRESIDENT, A TREND OF
CRIMINALIZING AND DEHUMANIZING
ALL IMMIGRANTS, AND THE QUESTION
WAS ABOUT GANG MEMBERS WHO WERE
>> Tucker: I'M NOT HERE TO
DEFEND ALL OF TRUMP'S VIEWS, BUT
WAS ASKED ABOUT MS-13 AND HAS
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR MORE
THAN A YEAR, AND HE SAID, THEY
ARE ANIMALS.
YOU MAY NOT LIKE THE TERM, IT'S
IMPRECISE OR WHATEVER, BUT IS
THERE NO ONE ELSE YOU CAN
DEFEND?
ARE THERE NOT OTHER WHERE THE
PEOPLE BEING ATTACKED?
DO YOU WAKE UP IN THE MORNING
AND ASK YOURSELF, HOW DO IT HERE
AND ASK YOURSELF, HOW DO IT HER
HERE?
>> I'M NOT SURE WHAT I YOU MEAN.
I STARTED THIS INTERVIEW BY
SAYING I'M NOT HERE TO DEFEND
ANY CRIMINALS -- >> NO HUMAN
BEING IS AN ANIMAL, THAT'S WHAT
>> BUT HE'S
ARGUING.
>> SO WE ARE ALL ANIMALS.
JUST AS A BIOLOGICAL QUESTION.
MAYBE THE TERM IS IMPRECISE,
MAYBE YOU DON'T LIKE IT, BUT YOU
ARE RUSHING TO THE DEFENSE.
AND IT'S NOT JUST YOU, IT'S JOHN
HARWOOD, AND THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY WHO IS UNABLE TO ADMIT
THAT THE IMMIGRANTS SHOULDN'T BE
HERE.
AND MS-13 IS PART OF THAT.
>> I THINK WE AGREE ON THAT
THE HISPANIC COMMUNITY TO TRY TO
ROOT THOSE BAD APPLES OUT OF
THERE.
>> Tucker: WHAT ABOUT THE HAS
BEEN A COMMUNITY?
>> SO THEY WON'T REPORT CRIMES
AND GO TO THE POLICE.
>> Tucker: THE HISPANIC
COMMUNITY DOESN'T HAVE THE
MONOPOLY ON CONCERNS OF ALL
AMERICANS OF ALL COLORS,
BACKGROUNDS AND FINESSE TO
FINESSE TO ETHNICITIES ABOUT
CRIMES.
AMERICANS DON'T WANT ANIMALS
LIKE THIS IN THE COUNTRY.
AGAIN, I JUST ASK YOU, WHY DID
I THINK THAT'S A WEIRD RESPONSE.
>> I THINK YOU HAVE TO PUT
THINGS IN CONTEXT AND I WILL DO
THAT FOR YOU.
THE CONTEXT HERE HAS TO DO WITH
A LARGER -- WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
CALLING IMMIGRANTS RAPISTS, AND
CALLING OTHERS FINE PEOPLE.
IT HAS TO DO WITH A CONSTANT
REFERRAL TO CRIMINALITY.
>> Tucker: FIRST OF ALL, THEY
HAVE -- WHATEVER, THEY ARE NOT
REQUIRED BY THE CONSTITUTION TO
COMPLEMENT IMMIGRANTS.
SORRY.
SECOND, YOU MAY NOT AGREE WITH
SPECIFIC CASE, HE IS CRITICIZING
PEOPLE WHO ARE EVIL, AND ARE
KILLING, ONCE AGAIN, THE POOR
AND THE DEFENSELESS.
AND YOU HAVE BEEN DRIVEN SO
CRAZY BY TRUMP THAT YOU CAN'T
EVEN ACCEPT THAT AS TRUE.
IF I ACCEPT CHARLES MANSON AS AN
ANIMAL, DOES THAT BOTHER YOU?
>> OF COURSE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
BUT GUESS WHAT, LAST YEAR, ICE
ARMRESTS
SO FOCUS ON THAT.
FOCUS ON THOSE WHO HAVE NO
CRIMINAL RECORDS.
>> Tucker: PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY SHOULD BE DEPORTED.
THAT'S WHAT THE LAW SAYS.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE LAW,
CHANGE IT IN CONGRESS.
>> THEN YOU SHOULD NOT FOCUS ON
CRIMINALS.
YOU SHOULD NOT SPEND YOUR TIME
AND ENERGY OF MOST PEOPLE IN THE
BAD NUMBERS.
>> Tucker: I'M SICK OF BEING
TOLD BY FOREIGNERS ABOUT WHO WE
THE LAW SAYS IF YOU ARE HERE
WOULD GET DEPORTED AND I FEEL
SAD ABOUT THAT, BUT THAT'S A
LOT.
>> WE WERE ALSO CRITICIZING THAT
LAST WEEK.
>> FOREIGNERS HAVE NO RIGHT TO
WEIGH IN ON OUR ASYLUM LAWS
BECAUSE THEY ARE FOREIGNERS AND
WE ARE CITIZENS.
FINAL QUESTION.
WHY DOES IT NOT BOTHER YOU WHEN
I CALLED CHARLES MANSON AN
ANIMAL, BUT IT DOES BOTHER YOU
WHEN TRUMP CALLS MS-13 ANIMALS?
>> IT BOTHERS ME WHEN ANY
CRIMINAL COMMIT SUCH HEINOUS
ACTS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SEEMS TO
UNDERSTAND VERY WELL WHAT SPEAKS
TO THE TRUMP BASE, BUT HE IS
ALSO NOT SPEAKING TO THE OTHER
SOCIETIES.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
ARE YOU THE APPOINTED LEADER OF
HISPANICS NOW?
HOW DID YOU GET THAT JOB, WERE
YOU ELECTED TO IT?
>> NO, I'M NOT SPEAKING FOR
HISPANICS.
>> VERY QUICKLY, HOW DO -- >>
THEY ARE FEELING THAT VIOLENCE
AND TRYING TO COME TO THE
COUNTRY, BUT YOU ARE CALLING
THEM PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF OUR LEGAL
SYSTEM.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE MS-13
VICTIMS ARE PEOPLE IN HONDURAS.
>> Tucker: LAST THING, I HAVE
TO GO.
PLEASE TO CONVINCE THE DEMOCRATS
TO RUN IN DEFENSE OF MS-13.
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE A MAJOR
MISTAKE TO DEFEND ANY CRIMINAL.
>> Tucker: BUT YOU DO.
THANK YOU, GREAT TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT.
EVEN WHEN HE ADMITTED THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS TALKING
HIMSELF FROM DEFENDING MS-13.
JOHN HARWOOD WEIGHED IN ON
TWITTER AS HE OFTEN DOES"
HOWEVER REPUGNANT THEIR ACTIONS"
THEY ARE HUMAN BEINGS IN MY
OPINION.
>> HE DOES THINGS LIKE CALL
IMMIGRANTS ANIMALS.
>> THE DEFENSE IS THAT HE WAS
FOLLOWING UP BY A STATEMENT BY
HE WAS JUST TALKING ABOUT MS-13.
GOOD ENOUGH?
A SLIPPERY SLOPE WHEN YOU START
DEHUMANIZING PEOPLE THIS WAY.
THAT'S WHAT THE NAZIS DATA,
THAT'S WHAT SLAVE OWNERS DID.
THAT'S NOT WHAT HUMANS DO.
>> LARRY O'CONNOR IS AN
ASSOCIATE OF THE WASHINGTON
TIMES AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THAT'S NOT WHAT AMERICANS DO,
LARRY.
>> I DON'T EXPECT MUCH FROM ANNA
NAVARRO.
YOU KNOW WHAT I FOUND MOST
TELLING ABOUT THAT CLIP?
CHRIS CUOMO, HE SAYS HIS DEFENSE
IS -- HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
MS-13.
THAT'S NOT HIS DEFENSE, THAT'S A
FACT, IT'S THE TRUTH.
THAT'S THE TRUTH THAT THE MEDIA
DIDN'T REPORT.
BUT FOR CHRIS CUOMO TO ACT LIKE,
HOW COULD THIS BE?
THAT'S LIKE SAYING I CAN'T
FAMILY AND CHRIS CUOMO, OR ANY
OTHER ITALIAN-AMERICAN.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
AND THIS IS MY BIGGEST PROBLEM.
AS YOU SAID, YOU SEE
AND ALL THESE OTHER PEOPLE WHO
ARE CONDEMNING REMARKS BASED ON
YOU WOULD THINK YOU WOULD SEE
SOME CORRECTIONS.
THE BEST THEY HAVE IS, EVEN
MS-13 DESERVES TO NOT BE
DEHUMANIZED.
ANIMALS, IF YOU CAN'T CALL THEM
OUT ON REPULSIVE BEHAVIOR,
YOU'VE SURRENDERED YOUR ABILITY
TO MAKE ANY MORAL JUDGMENTS IN
OUR SOCIETY.
>> Tucker: THE FIRST DRAFT,
AND I DON'T DO TOO MANY MEDIA
SEGMENTS BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THEY
ARE JUST DUMB, BUT THE FIRST
DRAFT OF THEIR STORY SAID TRUMP
HAD ATTACKED UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS.
>> MIGRANTS, OR MANY WHO CROSS
THE BORDER.
>> Tucker: SO THAT WAS A
DEMOCRATIC TALKING POINT.
>> IT WAS AN ABSOLUTE LIE.
COMPLETELY DOWN THE MIDDLE, AND
I THINK USUALLY THEY ARE, THEY
DID THE SAME THING.
THESE BE REPORTERS' IN-KIND
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE DEMOCRATIC
COMMITTEE?
>> THE ASSOCIATED PRESS BY THE
SEEN WHO FULLY RETRACTED IT AND
DELETED THEIR TWEETS.
BUT WHY ARE THEY CALLED UPON ANY
ETHICS QUESTIONS?
THEY SAID, FURTHER CONTEXT,
SUGGESTING IT WAS OUT OF CONTEXT